Let's have a look at how engineers
can help create your product.
If there's a difference between
how your app works right now, and
how you hope it will work in the future,
then you probably need an engineer.
For your start-up, let's focus on
front end, back end, mobile, and
data engineers.
So, what's a front end engineer?
A front end engineer helps
design the look of your app,
create interactions, and
build the overall user experience.
They'll make responsive interfaces so
that your app is accessible no
matter what device your user has.
Take a little time to explore
some of your favorite web apps.
Is there anything you like about them?
Maybe there's something
you find a bit awkward.
Either way, that's something
a front end engineer developed.
How about a back end engineer?
Back end engineers build and
maintain the technology that
powers your servers and databases.
They're responsible for storing and
distributing this data to
the rest of your team.
As your business scales,
back end engineers will help create
the infrastructure necessary
to continue running smoothly.
Now, let's look at mobile engineers.
Mobile-based apps are native apps you
download and run on your Android or
iOS phones.
A mobile engineer is responsible for
building this mobile-based
functionality.
They're able to improve
mobile performance, and
test apps on new devices.
Common types of mobile engineers
are Android and iOS developers.
Mobile engineers can give direct
access to Bluetooth, Gyroscope, and
Accelerometer functionality
within your app.
And finally, what's a data engineer?
Data engineers focus on
developing the architecture your
business needs to collect,
manage, and analyze data.
They have some similar responsibilities
to back end engineers.
They help distribute data to your team
by creating the data pipelines necessary
to collect and organize your data.
This will help you make data-driven
decisions for your business, so
you can more accurately meet
the needs of your users.
There's so much more you can learn about
these different types of engineers.
But, now that you know a little,
do you see yourself needing any of
these skills for your business?